نذهب الى روسيا كيف كانت في عام 20 22
زميلنا عبد الجواد رشد مراسل صباح العربيه
سيطلعنا من هناك على روسيا المتجمده
حراريا ولكن احداثها ساخنه دوما ماذا لديك
عبد الجواد قبل ان تذهب الى المنزل لانه
برد كثير واضح
[موسيقى]
صباح الخير نادين وصباح الخير لسهام وصباح
الخير اللي صباحا العربيه كل عام وانتم
بخير قد لا يكون عام 2002 و20 هو الافضل
بالنسبه للحياه في روسيا خلال هذه الفتره
باعتبار ان موسكو تدخل صراعا من العيار
الثقيل مع الغرب قد يكون الاكبر لها عبر
التاريخ لكن رغم السوداويه الوضع الا ان
عجله دوران الحياه في روسيا وفي موسكو ما
زالت مستمره معظم الاحداث التي كانت مقرره
خلال عام 2022 تمت بالكامل الاحتفالات رد
ان من راس السنه اعياد لكريسماس عيد النصر
عيد المراه معظم همم يعني اوقات السنه
كانت تعيش اوقات احتفالات كما هو مقرر
الوضع الثقافي وضع المسارح وضع الموسيقى
الحفلات الوضع الرياض طبعا رغم العقوبات
الكبيره التي قالت كافه ارجاء المشاركه
على الصعيد الدولي الا ان الاحداث
الداخليه في روسيا ما زالت قائمه حتى ان
فصل الشتاء كما تشاهدين دين قد جاء مبكرا
هذا العام هذه هي ثلوج موسكو يعني التي
تصلوا عاده بهذه الكميات في شهر مارس او
في شهر يعني ابريل القادم الا انها اليوم
في شهر ديسمبر تملا طبعا اراضي وضاحات
وحدائق وشوارع مدينه موسكو الوضع مستقر
نوعا ما في ظل طبعا الاخبار العاجله التي
نسمعها على مدار الساعه مع الازمه
الاوكرانيه هناك لكن طبعا مع سوداويه
الموضوع كما تحدث الشعب الروسي ما زال
مؤمنا بالحياه مؤمنا بالسلام مؤمنا بالحب
يحاول يصادف رساله السلام انا اتحدث عن
الشعب بشكل عام عبر مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي الى الشعب الاوكراني الذي
يعتبره شقيقا طبعا خلال 20022 تحدثنا الى
مئات الاشخاص في روسيا حول وضع الشعب
الاوكراني معظمهم يقولون بان الشعب
الاوكراني هو الشعب الشقيق الاول لروسيا
ولا هم تاريخ عريق يربط البلدين على مدار
100.000 السنين تحياتي لكم ولجميع افراد
صباح العربيه ولمخرجون الرائع ولجميع يعني
الاشخاص المجهولون خلف كوادر الكاميرات كل
التحيات